so you're in a high-stress situation and
you do what we all do bargain with the
big man God if that person is alive I
will go to church on Sunday okay I
promise I swear I swear this and even as
you wait for a sign any sign we all know
in the back of our minds that our
promises are kind of MD okay God if I'm
not pregnant I will change my facebook
status from atheist to agnostic I don't
care what any of us are religiously when
it comes down to it you will try to
strike a bargain good
shit shit shit shit yeah she's dead yeah
dead
yeah
okay god
if you help you bury this body isn't it
weird like no matter how or where were
raised at certain moments in our life we
just instinctively reach out to the
universe for help
church every Sunday I really try very
good samaratin I will not commit anymore
since college
shit I don't know why we do it I mean
does this mean that we sent some higher
power energy out there are we just
fucking kidding ourselves okay God if
you help me get away with these two I
mean whatever the reason may be we have
to take responsibility for our own
actions don't blame or bargain with a
higher power that's not spiritualities
for even though I do it too and that
yeah I mean we can't control everything
around us but we can certainly control
our reactions
nine-one-one can I help you hi oh my god
I like just a witness to hit and run no
I was not the driver stay awesome Gotham
by the way I looked absolutely crazy
out there filming by myself throwing it
myself against the car throwing myself
on the floor pointing that good prop gun
around and I just look like a psychopath
so I hope you appreciated that
you